- J'ai eu une opération
à la jambe, puis nson.
MURIEL LIZOTTE, conjointe
de Pierre Lavallée
- Puis là, on avaements, là, ilt
pas de seuils adaptés. La salle
de bain, ça devenait compliqué.
- Pour demeurer chez lui,
Pierre Ladapter sa maison qu'ile
avec sa femme Muriel Lizotte.
En 2016, le couple dépose
du Programme d'adaptation
de domicile du gouvernement
du Québec, communément appelé
le PAD. évaluer les besoins. One
ensuite les plans et devis.
Ils obtiennent le feu vert p uni
plus tard.
- On a tout refait
- Oui, c'est ça. Fait que,
t a changé de bord.
- C'est l'entrepreneur
Alain Croteau qui effectuefait
entièrement la salle de bain
pour que Pierre puisse y accéder
en fauteuil roulant : douche
sans seuil, barres
- Dépenser 25 000 $ dansla salls
Quand on regarde tout
ce qu'il y a à faire, là
- Une chambre à coucher est
aménagée au rez-de-chaussée
de portes sont élargis.
Si on exclut les
demandés par le couple,e platef,
la facture totale grimpe à
50 000 $.
- Le PAD nous a donné 16 000.
C'est sûr que c'était nettement
insuffisant, là, dans notre cas.
du Québec gère le Programme
depuis 30 ans. L'aide finance 1,
n'a jamais été indexée.
Des montants supplémentaire
endant offerts
aux personnes à faible revenu
et celles qui ont besoin
PIERRE LAVALLÉE- Le gouvernemene
à des normes pour le programme
PAD, mais il te do
le financement pour aller ave,
Maison adaptée du Québec- Quand,
le client payait entre 2000 et
5000 de ses poches à 20 000.
- Dans une déclaration,
le cabinet de la ministre
de l'Habitation, AndréeLaforest.
... mais sans offrir plus de
détails.nières années,
plus de 10 000 per
ont déposé une demande jugée
admissible par le PAD,
abandonnés en cours de route.
Certainss décident,
par exemple, de déménager
adapter leur maison sont
ortants. D'autres
n'ont pas assez d'argent
pour en payer une partie.e
la moitié des projets quimarches
40 dossiers par année,ent.
Les autres, ils les abandonnent,
le monde 2020 à Montréal,
c'est la Ville qui gère
le programme d'adaptation
domiciliaire. L'aide financière
donc deux fois plus élevée
qu'ailleurs dans la province
Marie-Chantale .♪lva9
un accident lors d'un voyage.
Son conjoint et elle ont dûacheé
et l'adapter.
MARIE-CHANTALE SALne couple de
cadres de porte, une plateforme
élévatrice, une salle de bain,
agrandir une porte de garage...
Pff! C'evait entamé des
démarches pour bénéficier du
PAD, mais a finalement laissé
deux ans d'attente à l'époque.
Pour cette mère de famille,
ça ne valait pas le coup
pour une subventio
- Tu t'arranges avec
tes problèmes. C'est sûr
mais je trouve ça dommage que
si j'ava
de la route, ça aurait été payé
à 100 % pratiquement.
d'adapta
sera revu.
- Qu'on considère l'inflation
travaux.
- 30, 40 000 de subvention
on se parle, ça serait pasexagé.
- Si on veut que les gens
restent à la maisger...
Ouais, faut donner les moyens
qui vont